Pulling down all the data
will reduce latency
and maximize
the battery efficiency.
But it's unlikely the user
is going to read every article,
so you'd just be wasting
a lot of bandwidth.
Downloading all the articles
without pictures,
actually doesn't
improve our efficiency
if you're just downloading
the front page,
because you'll still need
to activate the radio
to download those pictures
whenever an article is selected.
The right answer is to get
the headlines and the articles
linked to from that front page,
because they're the most likely
to be read as the user starts
browsing through the app.
You can then incrementally
download more articles
each time the user moves into an area
you haven't prefetched for yet.